e
d'une école techniquequququi abs
de l'armée Russe.
Quatre missiles ukrainiens
l'ont réduit en poussière
quelques minutes à peine après
le nouvel an. Ces images de
laskskskskskskskskskskskskskskss
à Makiivka, une banlieue de
k.k.k.k. Le blogueur militaire
russe Rybar identifie l'écolee t
qu'elle abritait 600 soldats.
Fait injabituel, le porte-parole
du ministère russe de la Défense
reconnaît la frappe
explosive sur ce qu'il qualifie
de centre de déploiement
63 militaires tués.
L' I I I I I I I I I I I I I I ,
plus connu sous le nom de
nenenenene, de plus en plus
critique à l'égard des échecs
de l'armée russe en Ukraine,
a parlé grgrgrgrgram de
"centaines de morts et blessés"
dans ce seul bombardement.
Au m
de la  o o o o on parle
de 400 morts et 300 blessés
du fait de la présence
d'tatatatatatatatatatatatatatat.
La milice pro-russe de
la République de Donetsk a aussi
endommagés dans la ville
en précisant que l'Ukraine
avait mené un bombardement
Des dommages ont été infli
à une multitude de bâtiments
résidentiels, de magasins,
des bibliothèques et de
écoles. Kiev et d'autres v
d'Ukraine ont encore été
russes, mais moins intensément
que lors du noses frappes ont vs
fabriques de drones afin,
selon elle, de déjouer
des attaques terroristes
en planification.
Nouvelles attaques confirmées
par le maire de Kiev Vitali
Klischko qui a passé la veille
du nouvel an au front
à Bakhmut. En 2023 a-t-il dit,
tous ceux qui sont venus
enUkUkUkUkUkUkraine vont
la quitter les pieds devant.
Défiant lui aussi, le président
Volodymyr Zelensky dans sondedes
russes hors de combat
en ne souhaitant qu'une seule v.
Jean-Michel Leprinc